- Can I get a medium coffee.
- [Barista] Sure.
- Actually what has the most caffeine?
- [Barista] We've got a grande macchiato
with like some colombian beans...
- [Man] Did I turn the stove off?
(hip hop music)
- [Redhead] Hey.
- Hey.
How are you?
- Good, you?
- [Redhead] Good, did I tell you the news about my cat?
- No.
Oh (beep) what's her name?
I don't remember, (beep).
(phone ringing)
- We're just gonna wait for a few more people.
- [Female] Am I supposed to be in this meeting?
- [Male] Oh wait, I didn't even make breakfast
that's why I'm at the coffee shop.
- [Female] Oh (beep) what was she talking about?
- [Blonde Woman] I don't even like this job.
- [Male] All the days just blend together.
- [Female] I can't even pick out key words.
- [Blonde Woman] I won't be surprised if I got fired.
- [Male] Oh no, I have to poop.
- [Blonde Woman] They definitely think I'm an (beep)hole.
- [Female] I should probably stop
thinking to myself, if i'm going to hear her.
- [Male] Don't poop at work.
- [Blonde Woman] My best friend isn't even really
my best friend, she has like three other best friends right?
- [Male] What if the bathroom is full?
I'll hold it.
Or is that how people get sepsis?
I need to see a doctor.
- [Female] I need to see a therapist.
- [Blonde Woman] I need a drink.
- [Female] How am I getting older and not getting smarter?
- [Male] Doctor's gonna tell me I'm dying.
- [Blonde Woman] Oh god, what is my mom doing?
She hasn't called in a few days.
Shut up.
- [Female] Shut up.
- [Male] Shut the (beep) up.
- [Female] Oh my god, I'm glad no one can hear my thoughts.
- [Blonde Woman] No one can hear my thoughts, right?
- [Man] Who's that?
- [Blonde Woman] Who's that?
- [Female] Oh no.
People can hear my thoughts I knew it.
- [Male] I'm losing my mind.
- [Blonde Woman] Are you thinking what I'm thinking?
- [Man] Maybe.
- [Female] Mind orgy.
- [Male] What?
- [Voiceover] Mind orgy.
- [Woman In Suit] Kelsey.
- [Redhead] I should probably keep going there right?
- Yeah.
There you go.
- Thank you.
- [Barista] Sir?
- Kelsey?
- Can I get you something to drink?
- I just gotta, I gotta, I gotta quit so...
- Okay.
- [Barista] Sir.
- I uh, I left my stove on.
(curious music)